turning now to something that millions
of Americans are doing today and of
course we're talking about traveling for
the Thanksgiving holiday many people are
already they've hit the road or they're
preparing to head out Chris Van Cleave
is one of those early risers he's
traveling from New York to Washington
today Chris good morning to you well it
looks like you're moving at a pretty
good clip so so so far so good
well Gail we've hit at least 25 miles an
hour this morning good morning and we
know this is probably about as good as
it's going to get as we're making our
way to Washington DC you can take a a
look outside as we're approaching New
York City traffic volumes are expected
to rise as the day goes on
nothing says the Thanksgiving Rush is on
like miles of brake lights in Los
Angeles it's exactly the kind of backup
Kevin regatti is hoping to avoid on his
drive from D.C to New Jersey usually
brutal trying to get all the way up so
I'd rather just do that today instead of
having to wait until tomorrow while the
average price of gas has dropped 14
cents in the last week at 360 a gallon
it's still the highest Thanksgiving at
the pumps since AAA started keeping
track
it's
extremely hard just to fill up my tank
so I'm not traveling I'm staying local
this year just a verbal warning all
right because this holiday weekend is
typically one of the deadliest on the
roads police Nationwide are stepping up
patrols hopefully
people slow down when they see us
the airports continue to see crowds at
pre-pandemic levels Amtrak says it too
is expecting its busiest week of the
year I like the training I just sit down
and I don't feel as anxious or anything
AAA expects trips by train bus and
cruise ship to jump 23 percent this
Thanksgiving in Miami this week Carnival
launched its newest vessel the
celebration with a sold out six day
Thanksgiving Caribbean cruise Carnival
plans to serve up 36 thousand pounds of
turkey on its ships this week something
Tisa Curry's family is looking forward
to sampling after the pandemic we hadn't
really got together that much and we
wanted to get together as a family and
take a cruise
and this is pretty open driving AAA
expects the worst of it today to be
between 11 A.M and 8 P.M if you're
looking for your drive home think
Saturday afternoon or early Sunday
morning or probably your Best Bets Nate
Chris thank you